hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday
monday morning podcast and i'm just
checking in
[Music]
on you
because you're
special even though you haven't done
[ __ ] today
um what's going on how are you
how are you hanging in there
i'm [ __ ] hanging in there i got my
last road date
god damn it
i was in st louis
denver
minneapolis reno
san jose atlanta
long beach
[ __ ] somewhere else
i know i missed something detroit
milwaukee
and now i'm in vegas
then this [ __ ] run
is done
it's over
i get to chill out come back and enjoy
thanksgiving week i'm very very thankful
to be doing that i will be doing some
press during the week because you know
show business never sleeps
um f is for family
season five is coming out
i think i know the date is it november i
thought it was a day after thanksgiving
or is it on thanksgiving i don't know
it's coming out this week the last one
we wrap it up people
we wrap it up with the murphy family f
is for family season five
what do we got here f is for family
season five
f is for family season five
why won't you just say when it's coming
out
season five jesus christ
date
november 25th bam
bam bam
the fifth and final one very proud
um
of this series and i was psyched that
they let us know that this was the last
season so we could you know we thought
we were going to do another season we
would have ended it with some sort of
cliffhanger but instead we got to wrap
it up so it'll be very satisfying
hopefully with the fans
um and if it isn't then we will where
the torch is over
i love people when they get mad at a
season finale
like a a series finale
well that wasn't satisfying at all like
how much is it really the show
like
was the series finale
not satisfying
you know to that level or is is it
really that your life isn't that
satisfying
and now that this show's over
you don't have a new show to distract
you from the things that you need you
know you need to take care of and you're
not taking care of them
and all of a sudden you just you you're
just not looking at the tv and you're
just looking around the room
ah you're looking at your life
tv turns off and you catch your
reflection on the flat screen
is that me what the [ __ ] happened to me
right like in one of those those crazy
movies that that [ __ ] guy makes there
the mulholland drive guy
i i did i tell you i watched her erase
her head
i finally saw that thing man
um
david something rather
i just can't imagine if you hit that guy
like
telling his parents
the [ __ ] is this thing here
i literally slid the finger you know i'm
on my little thingy on my laptop and all
of a sudden this thing [ __ ] comes up
says what can i help you with what you
can first of all you can introduce
yourself who the [ __ ] are you
and it starts everything i'm saying it's
like voice texting
like right across the screen
goddamn things
what'd i say eraserhead
racerhead
the original
directed by david lynch
jesus christ i bet after eraserhead when
they were hey you want to go see i got
made another movie you want to come down
uh you know what
i just realized i had something to do
[Laughter]
i just want to know what we did wrong
do you make these movies because of us
was it something we did were you born
this way can you just let us know what
it is david
um
yeah anyway so yeah season five f is for
family wrapping it up
um
you know thanks to gomot netflix
mike price and everybody who made it
happen uh what a ride vince vaughn
beta billy's like
victoria vonnegut's list a million
people all right
um mo collins
forgot to give her a shout out last week
there's a million people that worked on
the show um so thank you to everyone and
i hope you guys uh i hope you enjoy it
i hope you enjoy it and then my life
i think i want to say it's going to slow
down a little bit because i've been on
the road and i'll tell you something
going on the road going to the airport
walking by the cinnabons and the [ __ ]
all the goddamn
the [ __ ] was that noise
i swear to god everybody on my [ __ ]
block is redoing that goddamn house
it's unbelievable
it's
unbelievable if i'm not hearing the
sound of a [ __ ] leaf blower
somebody's got a jackhammer
i'm going nuts you know i'm a comedian i
try to take my old man nap during the
day i got young kids right
my son goes down for his nap
my daughter you know she's at school i
[ __ ] i try to take a nap i just you
know i'm a light sleeper
i'm not a relaxed guy i don't know if
you guys know that i was always envious
of those people they could just like
[ __ ] sleep in a train station
like you ever see somebody and you're
like is that person homeless or are they
one of those people that can just sleep
anywhere
you know you know those people you get
on a plane and before people even done
boarding they're already asleep
you know like a dog you know dogs do
that
the second then i don't have to chase
anything they're not worried about
intruders they're just their eyes get
heavy and their body just shuts down
and they go to sleep
and i never understood that until i
started getting acting work
and they'd be like all right you have a
little break just go back to your
trailer for a second you'd be like all
right and you'd sit in your trailer and
for like three minutes and all of a
sudden you're like
oh my i could sleep for [ __ ] eight
hours right now i think your body just
that goes back to like caveman days
where like at any second
you know
some predator could just come into the
cave and you had to run for your [ __ ]
life so if the coast was clear
your body's like all right well if we're
not going to be
there's no reason for us to up like a
laptop we're gonna power down now and
save the battery life because god forbid
god forbid um i was always amazed
at people that could do [ __ ] like that
um
i never could do that [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ]
i'm a light sleeper
you know
anything happens i [ __ ] my eyes open
up
and then i'm walking downstairs with
that my little mini [ __ ]
whatever like you know golf club a
[ __ ] bat whatever i have underneath
there
whatever
blunt object i can [ __ ] find
you know oh god
is there anything worse
than having a fight in your underwear
i've never had it i've never had to do
that but i would just think that that's
you just got to feel so exposed that's
another reason why the [ __ ] ufc
and professional fighters are so tough
is they fight in their underwear
you know
just walking i mean the boxers don't
they come in with their shorts on
you know
those hooker boots right but like the
[ __ ] ufc people they come in they're
like barefoot they literally look like
you know what's amazing if you ever
broke into a [ __ ] ufc fighter's
[ __ ] house at night
[Music]
i mean they're just ready to go i mean
not only do they have the training
they're dressed the same way they do
when they go into the [ __ ] octagon i
mean just how [ __ ] you are
um
man they must sleep great
provided they didn't have a fight that
night you know what i mean or that week
or whatever however long it takes them
to recover
do you know if you got a black belt in
something you know
but then again you are going to sleep
and if you do combat all the time
there's people always attacking you
maybe you become nervous to sleep i
don't know how it works
i don't know if you know this about you
about me guys i was never in the
professional fight game i know that
surprises you
i know that's something where you kind
of like well hey bill you know
the way you uh you know describe fat
people at airports i would have thought
you had some sort of uh martial arts
background well surprisingly not you
know i'm full of surprise people
it's not the case so i've been on the
road and uh hitting the elliptical and
doing all of that [ __ ] but i'm sort of
on a holding pattern trying to lose
weight i mean you just can't [ __ ]
lose weight if you go on the road you
can maintain
you can maintain that's the best i've
been able to do and then i tweaked my
[ __ ] shoulder
once again i didn't [ __ ] it up again i
just tweaked it so i just had somebody
work it out for me hey work it out okay
baby all right
um
i get all [ __ ] frustrated with it and
[ __ ]
so um
i don't know so back to the drawing
board so now i have to lower the weight
that i'm using and it's just like
i don't know i have a couple of dumb
bets out there that i think i'm gonna
lose
okay i have a bet with paul versey
that when i turn 70
i'm gonna uh
i'm gonna be able to do ten
ten [ __ ] pull-ups
i mean he could have won that bet if i
said i'd be able to do it at fifty and i
made the bet when i was like 47
and the second i made that bet i don't
know what happened
my shoulders just
went on me so
trying to work my way back
and then i have another
bet
i have a bet
that
at some point
kyler murray
is uh
is gonna have a weight issue
something about his face i don't know
what it is i just think
[Music]
there's gonna be a moment when in the
next five years where they're gonna say
you know you know he put on some weight
during the off season he could have been
in better shape i don't know what i just
need him to if he wins mvp or a couple
of playoff games i don't know what it is
i'm just i look at his face and he just
i see it in there
[Music]
i actually made
a bet with somebody
about that those are my two dumb beds
you got any dumb bets out there
you know what's the dumbest thing you
ever gambled on
you know i made money with on version we
went to uh the masters in 2010 and we
were gambling on the turtles we were on
like i don't forget what hole we were on
it's the one that has the water right in
front of the hole
no really bill it's probably most of
them it's after our men corner
and there's a par-3 right after it
perpendicular to it
i used to know what hole it was
um
15 or something like that and i think
that the par 3 was a
was it 16 i think i don't know what but
we were sitting there just waiting for
him to come through
and um
there were turtles sitting on rocks that
we were gambling
on which turtle would go under the water
next which was really easy it's like the
one with the driest shell
and uh you know
paul wasn't you know he wasn't good at
it he's italian you know they like stuff
that's shiny they grab it towards
gravitate towards that everything's got
to be [ __ ] right you know
furniture the rug the carpet
white leather you know pristine
you know so i think he saw that shine on
the on
i wish he was here to hear this
he saw the shell and it was like it was
glitter in like the chain around his
neck and he just couldn't lay off
and i actually i actually made some
money i really have no idea what the
[ __ ] i'm talking about right now um oh
another thing i watched the rough cut of
my potential special from red rocks
um
oh my god if you want to [ __ ] hate
yourself watch yourself for a good hour
and a half
uh on a rough cut
that isn't uh
color corrected
and the side isn't mixed or anything it
sounds like you're bombing they have the
crowd super low
and um
oh my god
i walked out of there i was like i don't
know if i've ever been funny in my life
nobody's like no dude it's great it's
great i'm telling you it's great we're
gonna mix it everything will look
[ __ ] great that's what everything is
i remember talking to this guy the first
time he ever made a movie
i was a movie i was a fan of and i met
this director and he goes you know
what's funny about that that was my
first movie
and when i looked at the the initial
rough cut
he goes i thought i had ruined my life
because he oh he's making an independent
movie after her having done some studio
things and he was so like distraught
that
he got off the subway and left the cut
of the movie on the train
i never had they must not have been the
master or something like that i don't
know what he just left it on the [ __ ]
train
oh [ __ ] so
anyway i got through with those i was
psyched they used to take me you know my
early specials this is the level of
self-loathing
that i had that it would take me
like
and this is back i just had to look at
an hour of stuff
and i would be like all right i'm gonna
do
like
12 minutes a day
monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
and i'll be done by friday
and i would literally do that
and i would watch and i would think i
would feel like i was coming up on 10
minutes and i'd only watched three
minutes
i mean it was [ __ ]
i don't know what it was it was bananas
like i could literally could not
i couldn't handle it and now i've gotten
to the point
um i sat down and i watched all of this
[ __ ] grant cause i was watching it with
other people
so i was like all right
and i just kept staring at the time code
ah [ __ ]
17 minutes
[Music]
look at my head
[Laughter]
ah god i'm old i mean that's all you're
thinking you can't hear the [ __ ]
jokes it's so it's a [ __ ] but i got
through it
so now the fun part you know i made some
notes and stuff and uh we're gonna
tighten the thing up and then
you lock it this is what we want and
then they color correct it and then they
make it look great you know like oh my
god i do like myself
uh liquid death everybody i love liquid
death good for them good for them doing
something about these water bottles man
do your part drink liquid death
all right
it's trying to [ __ ] leave something
for young people
and the animals
you know from the and the [ __ ]
animals that date all those women liquid
death is death to plastic there are
enough plastic bottles on the planet and
you don't need to help create more
liquid death is an easy way to do your
part i love liquid death
not only because it's great for the
environment it's delicious it's ice cold
water in an aluminum can that tastes so
much better
everything tastes better
in an aluminum can versus plastic your
soda everything
a can just tastes [ __ ] better it's
delicious i love it my
my refrigerator is stocked with them and
these aren't freebies from liquid death
i go to my local whole foods
soda sopa whole foods
and i stock my refrigerator with them i
love them absolutely love them i can't
say enough i love this company because
liquid okay the water is giving uh me
life why do they call it liquid death
because liquid death will brutally
murder your thirst murder and these
aluminum tall boys are infinitely
recyclable so they're bringing death to
plastic bottles death to plastic
uh if you have one crack open a can
while you're recording and take a gulp i
would have loved to have done that
but it's way over there my [ __ ]
my my refrigerator there liquid death
also donates 10 of the profits to help
kill plastic pollution forever try to
think of something more hardcore than
that spoiler you can liquid death
get some today the badass
all right roman everybody when the
moment for intimacy arrives you need to
be ready
roman ready whether you've been in a
relationship for years or just getting
started
that's hilarious whether you're tired of
banging her or
worried you know you're gonna be so
excited you're gonna get in your head
having the confidence that comes from
preparation means you're free to enjoy
the moment when the moment comes even
though you're far from ordinary the
truth is
erectile dysfunction is really common in
fact 52 percent of guys age 40 to 70
experience some form of erectile
dysfunction
go to getroman.com
now to speak to a u.s licensed
healthcare professional about erectile
dysfunction and get 15 off your first
month of treatment
e.d
is more common than most people think in
fact 52 of men between the ages of 40
and 70 will experience some form of
erectile dysfunction the benefits of ed
treatment can help you reconnect with
your partner and rediscover the joy of
sex roman ready is confidence
personified it is the self-assurance
that comes from knowing you've prepared
yourself for the moment when intimacy
arrives roman's system is completely
confidential and total totally discreet
no big logos or labels on packages with
roman you know with
roman i'm glad they do that you wouldn't
want to order that stuff and everybody
knows you know
you know you got a floppy sock there uh
roman with roman you can get a free
online evaluation in ongoing care for
erectile dysfunction all from the
comfort and privacy of your home a u.s
licensed healthcare professional will
work with you to find the best treatment
plan if medication is appropriate it
ships to you free with two-day shipping
the whole process is straightforward
convenient and discreet but sometimes it
hangs a little to the left thank you
getting started is simple just go to get
roman r-o-m-a-n-dot-com
b-u-r-r and complete an online visit
take care of your erectile dysfunction
without leaving your home complete an
online visit today to connect with a u.s
licensed health care professional and
take care of it go to
getromand.com today and if you're
prescribed get 15 off your first month
of ed treatment make sure you're ready
to have confidence and control this fall
roman ready
oh look who it is everybody knew
no
[Music]
you know when it comes to losing weight
something i can't seem to do there's a
lot of pressure out there to label foods
good or beyond
but that just creates unnecessary
dilemmas noom is here to change how we
see food with a psychologically based
approach that looks at what you eat
but also how you i should sign up for
this because i could understand why
that when i'm lonely on the road i go
right to that drawer of candy and just
start eating you know like billy fatface
on halloween instead of making you feel
guilt or regret noob empowers you to
keep going
not everyone wants to be on a strict
diet or do two a days at the gym or
drink questionable
teas
instead of trying to cram your life into
someone else's idea of help try noob
noom uses a psychological
psychology-based approach to find a
healthier balance that's moldable to
your life and as a result more
sustainable see that's the big thing the
sustainability everybody else is just
showing you how to cut weight
you know and then you just balloon back
up right at least that's what i do you
don't need rules to lose weight just the
knowledge and wisdom to empower you to
build smarter
more sustainable habits newm's weight
cognitive behavioral approach helps you
better understand your relationship with
food how to be more mindful of your
habits and gives you the knowledge and
support you need for long-lasting change
75 of newm users finished the program
and more than 60 percent of users
engaged with the with the program keep
the weight off for a year or more that's
what i'm talking about
start building better habits for
healthier long-term results sign up for
your trial at noom.com
mmp that's n o o m dot com slash mmp oh
look who it is everybody simply safe
if you ever wanted to make your home
feel safer there is no better time than
right now
this week my friends at simply safe are
giving my listeners early access to
their all
all their black friday deals
you know i saw that out of my peripheral
of my eye i thought it was for all black
families
of their award-winning home security i
love simply safe because it has
everything you need to make your home
safe indoor and outdoor
cameras that's a good idea though they
should give a discount in february for
black families
you know you can come off as progressive
you'll sell more stuff you know it's an
idea
right
then women would [ __ ] you know
valentine's day is also
in february how come we don't get a
discount on simply safe
is it cause we're hawaii and then he got
a [ __ ] show dumb idea sorry simply safe
i love simply safe because it has
everything you need to make your home
safe indoor and outdoor cameras
comprehensive sensors all monitored
around the clock by trained
professionals who send
help the instant you need it simply safe
was even named best home security system
of 2021 by u.s news and world report you
can easily customize the system for your
home online in minutes and even get free
custom recommendations from simply safe
these are simply safe's biggest
discounts of the year you can get a
complete home security system starting
at just over 100 dollars
there are no long-term contracts or
commitments it's a really easy way to
start feeling a bit more peace of mind
take advantage of simply safe early
black friday deals and get fifty percent
off your new home security system by
visiting simplysafe.com
again that's
simplysafe.com for fifty percent off
your entire system
okay lastly
but certainly not leastly stamps.com
you know you've heard me talk about
stamps.com they've been sponsoring the
show for over nine years now and if you
haven't tried it what are you waiting
for we gotta do some on the 10-year
anniversary
um
give out some stamps here uh whether
you're selling online or running an
office or a side hustle
hey we don't care what you're shipping
over here okay keep decided stamps.com
can save you so much time money and
stress during the holidays access all
the post office and ups shipping
services you need without taking the tip
the trip
oh the trip okay
and get discounts the tip i'm still
thinking about the roman and get
discounts you can't find anywhere else
like up to forty percent off usps rates
and seventy percent six percent off ups
going to the post office instead of
using stamps.com is kind of like taking
the stairs instead of the elevator just
going up a couple of floors sure take
the stairs walking up 30 flights a day
you could use a break if you spend more
than a few minutes a week dealing with
mail and shipping stamps.com is a
lifesaver you'll save so much time and
money you'll wonder why you didn't start
sooner save time and money this holiday
season with stamps.com sign up with the
promo code burp for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial free postage
and a digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page and enter bur
um anyway i got vegas this weekend baby
vegas baby
um
i got one show friday and one show
saturday they call me billy one show
oh billy [ __ ] uh
bags under the ice it's got one show
friday one show say
and then i'm hanging around to go to the
raiders
the formerly oakland los angeles back to
oakland raiders
i'm going to that um
and i think that's the they were they're
in the perfect town
the perfect time for where the fan base
dresses up and all of that [ __ ]
the vegas you know they should have some
[ __ ] you know what they should bring
some vegas showgirls
out you know with a patch over their eye
looking like truck stop [ __ ]
um that's what i would do get a little
theme going vegas loves the theme
no that's not why they're in a perfect
look they're in the perfect location
because they were in oakland they were
in la then back to oakland and then they
moved to vegas and if you look on your
on your maps
boys and girls at home
that
creates a triangular
shape of fans
right
la fans
oakland fans never gave up the raiders
when they went down to la they still
[ __ ] were watching them they hated
that they moved and then when they came
back they loved them even more they
brought them back and then they left
again oakland was like dating a stripper
and they didn't realize it right la
still loves the raiders so you got two
cities that still love them and then
they're in vegas so every [ __ ] drunk
that's going out there for his bachelor
party's like dude let's schedule my
bachelor party around the [ __ ]
weekend when the raiders are playing my
team
yeah i was trying to get tickets it was
really [ __ ] hard
uh not a lot of tickets
not a lot of uh tickets available out
there granted it is the you know maybe
people will take them for granted after
a while can you imagine if they [ __ ]
move again
you know
you know i think they go next
probably grand junction ohio i mean uh
colorado but they probably end up in
salt lake city
and that would be [ __ ] hilarious
you know all those flanders looking
white people out there
trying to look like pirates
[Laughter]
all of those holier-than-thou [ __ ]
guys
with the come white hair
and the [ __ ] you know nine wives they
all gotta ship you know big that stadium
would have to be if everybody brought
their wives
um
they probably don't do that you know
they probably bring like you know
whoever whatever wife was the best that
week to the jazz game
you know if you're gonna do that you
better make a better loaf of bread you
want to go to that
i'm sorry
you know well you know i don't know
don't tell me show me
wife number four has been crushing it
you need to be more like her
then all of a sudden wife number four he
gets really sick
out of nowhere because wife number seven
poisoned her because she's [ __ ]
jealous
and she wants to see john morant that
weekend
it's a slippery slope having more than
one wife
you've seen the real housewives can you
imagine having nine of those [ __ ]
things
you can do it in utah i don't think they
have cell phones out there yet where you
can really just [ __ ]
rule with an iron fist
let's look up domestic violence in utah
let's this would be a great google [ __ ]
do mormons
beat their wives
[Laughter]
all right mormon settlement fund
bsa sexual abuse claims all right that's
pretty pedestrian you see that in every
state lawsuit filed verse mormon church
get to okay
major victory
sexual abuse attorneys oh look at this
dude you know those mormons they just
stole that from us catholics
[ __ ] unoriginal people would you do
something else
um
what 75 years in the mormon church
taught me about assault
taught you you were in it for 75 years
how about you finally figured it out
the most shocking thing about the outing
of rob porter this week when is this
from 2018 who's rob porter
that just sounds like a utah name huh
how you doing rob rob porter
real estate
uh this week is that uh not that there
is another accused wife batterer
in the white house
the [ __ ] is this it's who did the outing
his mormon ex-wives
oh my god
why didn't they all gang up on him
mormon women pretty why are you blaming
the victim i'm just saying you know what
i mean
he wakes up one morning you guys are all
standing at the top of the hill behind
the house like [ __ ] braveheart
ladies ladies relax well i'm sorry just
[ __ ] kick his ass mormon winning
women pretty reliably show up
in comedy and drama as naive passive and
sweet mothers
gentle women
who do not take the reins in blowing up
an abuser and a criminal
yeah that's because the scripts are
written by hollywood liberals
um she couldn't be a strong woman if she
puts up with that
uh in bringing down porter jenny
willoughby
oh
genie willoughby and colby
holderness
are these real names
defied their church bishops who had
dismissed their allegations about he
punched and choked them and instead went
public they shared photographs indeed to
good for them of the alleged abuse and
refused to back down even in the face
of a president
who doubts them
oh this was that trump hate i mean let's
try to [ __ ] keep it where it
belongs all right with your [ __ ]
husband here
rob porter let's see let's see what old
rob porter's doing now rob
porter
utah
today
you know i recently got remarried you
know the four women putting my life back
together
well let's see
here would you look at this [ __ ] guy
i can see him you can look at the back
of his neck he can tell he gets angry
rob roger robert roger porter is an
american lawyer and former political
let's get to the controversy personal
life domestic abuse allegations
the more sections you have on your
[ __ ] wikipedia the worse it gets rob
porter it just sort of breaks you down
then it's political career personal life
domestic abuse allegations
um all right in late
november 2017 a girlfriend of porters
alerted her friend white house counsel
blo don mcgann
regarding porter's anger problems
porter's ex-wife oh
willoughby had sought and received a
three-day emergency protective order
against him in june 2010.
so they had to put up with this for
another seven years photographs of
holding us with a black eye in her
detailed accounts of porters alleged
abuse were also made public
oh my god dude that's just like let him
go to sleep get a [ __ ] skillet
and then put them in the backyard
despite their testimonies
and evidence presented porter denied his
ex-wife's alligator they were fighting
with each other
i was at work and resigned from his
staff she got kicked by a [ __ ] oxen
and resigned from his staff secretary
post after they became public oh
willoughby stated i don't want to be
married to him i would not recommend
anyone to date him or marry him but i
definitely want him
wait but i definitely want him in the
white house and the position he is in i
think his integrity and ability to do
the job is impeccable
she's protecting that alimony
that doesn't make any sense
you know you wouldn't want to date the
guy or be married to him because he'll
kick the [ __ ] out of the other woman but
i would love him to be in the white
house because of his i think his
integrity and his ability to do the job
are impeccable well you know hats off to
her from being able to separate the man
at home versus the man at work porter
resigned from his position at the white
house as white house staff secretary i
don't even remember this
i guess this is an old story
uh
porter said the allegations are false
and are part of a coordinated smear
campaign by what his wives the
washington post reported that the white
house council taught him again it's
known since january
um all right
wow
i mean that's a [ __ ]
that's a situation man you got all those
wives and then you start smacking them
around
you gotta eventually know they're coming
for the crown right
you can't do that you got to be a
sweetheart oh my god
more than one oh my god
if i had like four wives i would just
wake up in the morning
and just be like
hey ladies
how's it going
yeah yo everybody looks lovely
no one more so than the other
what are you guys feeling like you'd
like for breakfast
no no don't get up don't get up
are you feeling oatmeal you want
pancakes i'm a little sugary you want
eggs savory
crush breakfast and then i get the [ __ ]
out of there you know do the dishes i
would get the [ __ ]
out of there
then i come home
you know after working all day to
support their four [ __ ] mouths right
and then that first thing i would ask
him is i would ask them how their day
was
i think i could hold that front up for
about three days
and before i would just be like listen
you guys ever see flavor of love
all right that's right i forgot i didn't
allow you guys to watch tv well it was a
reality show on vh1
where flavor flav had to choose
between like 10 or 12 women
you know
i'd like to get
pick that show up here at home
in about episode 11 when he was down to
four women
okay here's the deal
i still want to be married but not to
all you
all right one of you guys
is gonna win and it all depends
on your behavior
over the weekend
all right
now here's the deal
sex is off the table it's too [ __ ]
easy
okay if it's just gonna be sex i'm still
gonna be married to all four you on
monday
okay what i'm looking for right now
stop crying what i'm looking for is the
intangibles
sorry that's me as a [ __ ]
is it a polygamist
a polygamist
um all right
monogamist
um
okay well that's the podcast everybody
uh everybody
yeah yeah who's that
move your body
yeah yeah
backstreet boys all right whatever the
[ __ ] it was
all right um that's the podcast but
before we go
we have me and paul versus uh bet mgm
um
segment here where we talk about our
picks and all that
and uh
our little gambling thing there and
after that we'll have a bonus
um episode half hour episode of the
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcasts from uh greatest
hits one from uh
i don't know what thursday about a year
ago i don't know a couple years ago
however andrew does it all right thank
you guys
uh and enjoy the bettam gm what's up
everybody it is week 11 of the nfl and
we are back with our bet mgm nfl segment
here guys bet mgm this season as you
know uh the anything better podcast has
teamed up with them we're having such a
great time we'll be using bet mgm lines
the best lines the most reliable lines
to make all of our picks and we'll have
special offers for our listeners each
week if you haven't signed up yet we've
got a special offer for our listeners
right now sign up for a new bet mgm
account use the code word bur okay burr
could not be more easy and you'll get 50
free uh bet just by signing up you're
gonna get fifty dollars just by signing
up go to the app sign up use b-u-r-r as
the code and uh that's it guys uh you
don't need uh you don't even need to
make a deposit dude they're just giving
you money all right to get getting in
the game paul
yes if you haven't signed up for bet mgm
yet you use a bonus code bur bur r
you'll get fifty dollars free tibet uh
use for this week's
game now
um apparently we messed up last week we
thought it was the week nine we messed
up as we ten as far as just telling
people people are hitting the stop going
it's week ten because there's a bye week
that was uh that was the issue okay
now
we had an interesting thing we messed up
because i went oh and four last week
well
you did something that's never been done
before since we've been doing this jimmy
the greek thing you did the unimaginable
and then and then followed it with the
unforgivable which i was being carried
off the field on on people's shoulders a
week ago and then last week now now i'm
like i'm gonna get oger on
i won the title you know i'm from the
state
y'all like me i'm gonna be here forever
better two years later right get the
[ __ ] out of here i feel like the way you
did it was better it kind of like you
said it's a game of runs you just showed
how you could give it back it's like
going to oh you know what happened paul
i talk [ __ ]
that's what happened i go look at me
against the spread not like these guys
on the money line and then is that oh
yeah
bill slap
snap
slap
0-4 and i hate this week i i couldn't i
couldn't [ __ ] spot a winner
all right well here's the thing
if you guys are paying attention and
following me and bill which i know that
you are this is how tight the race is
right now
uh myself paul versi is 20 and 20 after
40 picks and uh my guy bill burr is 20
19 and one
he is remaining a half game lead because
he has a push and he and here's the good
thing bill we are still 500 or above
weeks
i'm not talking anymore [ __ ] after this
week i don't know about this one paul
what's hilarious to me is that it's
almost 11 o'clock in the morning and
your eyes are puffy like you got up at 5
00 a.m oh dude you know me
nobody sleeps like paul i mean no i was
alcohol i was i was sleeping like an
angel
i was like west coast i look more awake
than you i don't know i was sleeping
like an angel the alarm went off what
are you gonna do i don't know what it is
i'll tell you what you can do you get
both your damn kids up and make them
[ __ ] pancakes
that's what you're gonna do as your wife
then comes down the stairs i forgot you
had a podcast
i could reheat these later
that's why they outlive us paul
all right
all right so now i love her
i love her man
she's the best
uh you get first pick
all right
i'm gonna take joe burrows
going out to vegas
minus one at the raiders
wow you're not taking the patriots
no because i know what's to happen
okay paul you're still going to ride
that train now everybody knows what the
[ __ ] they are they've won
a row they've got a lot of rest who the
hell's coming into town
i don't like their line actually
no they're playing with me to take the
patriots paul what are you trying to do
to me huh you trying to make me go in
eight
you [ __ ] all right go ahead
if somebody goes eight in a row wrong
they should just pitch to me over
if she came home you go eight in a row
dude you go all in for two weeks in a
row it's called the shot in the head
something we gotta have to something
all right here we go so if you go oh and
four two weeks in a row you're done
no but then that ends the game it's got
to be something you got to you have to
do something we'll figure it out it's an
instant yeah it's an instant cash prize
to the other guy if you go eight and if
you go for the unforgivable two weeks in
a row it's an instant 500 bucks to the
other guy
all right i like that
yeah and there's an asterisk next to
your name even if you win
you get the roger maris astric that's
[ __ ] hilarious all right i like that
i'm on the hot seat paul
and i i i don't see a winner this week
all right so you're taking joe burrows
to the and the uh cincinnati bengals
bengals yes you said it right not the
bangles the bengals all right ah
god
are the raiders done see dude now we're
at the place where i don't know what a
team is anymore cam newton comes back
and starts winning i mean what the
hell's going on in the yeah they're
running the wildcat that's it's cam
newton
did they forget the guy knows how to
throw the ball
yeah it's true guys got a great arm i
don't know what i don't know what
they're doing cam newton up the gut cam
newton around the side
what's so funny they were trying to get
rid of the guy they when they were
scrubbing his
face out all the photos like [ __ ]
joseph stalin or is it joseph paul
i'm good i'm going to take
you looked at these [ __ ] things no i
really i literally opened it this
morning
all right um i'm gonna take the san
francisco 49ers
against the jaguars because san
francisco the way they looked
the way they looked against the rams on
monday night was incredible
uh the defense was all over the place
jimmy somebody come back
give me g the house that was a different
team man that was good
i'm gonna i'm gonna see if and i think
if san francisco is gonna make a run
now's the time where they put it into
fifth gear i'm taking the niners minus
six and a half on the road against the
hapless jacksonville jaguars i'm staying
away from the jaguars for the rest of
the year every time i bet them i've lost
um
all right i'm taking the chiefs minus
two and a half at home against the
cowboys i don't think the chiefs are as
bad as everybody's saying
um i think the cowboys always fall apart
this time of year
it's just what they do
it's just i don't know
paul i'm i'm literally i'm i'm swinging
in the dark here
i like the chief the chiefs at home
mine is two and a half i think andy reid
does that off jesus andy reid this time
of year oh andy reid i mean i know that
one year he had a good time
no this is good for him he'll get you
the [ __ ] conference game
and once every 20 years he gets the
super bowl i don't think this is one of
those times
all right
i'm good why did andy reid have to take
a couple of hits there because i'm not
sure about my bet is that what it is
okay go ahead what do you got
yeah that was such a projection of your
insecurity
i was already yelling at andy reid for
not winning the bet the only thing you
didn't do was call him a fat piece of
[ __ ] during that
uh
entertaining i put on this covered
weight i can't really call anybody
i'm gonna take the carolina panthers
minus three at home against washington
cam newton's back he's going against his
old coach
um they seem to be rejuvenated and i
like the three points and what do you
think about the team from washington
last week when they raped tom brady in
the [ __ ] buccaneers i i had the
buccaneers just straight up kicked the
[ __ ] out of him
you're not buying it
no it's just a weird things are
happening weird right now so this is
literally shot in the dark but i'll take
that minus three okay
all right i'm gonna take the steelers
getting
five and a half in san diego
that's a [ __ ] great pick
[ __ ]
that's a great pick bill
well i mean it's been a while since i've
had a great pick paul
oh my god do i take the do i take the
tennessee titans
given 10 and a half against the [ __ ]
texans
oh such a weird game henry's out for the
rest of the year
ah all right dude
if henry's in that game you're gonna bet
that but the line's gonna go up
obviously
yeah dude i'm really this week is
this is a tough one man
the uh
[ __ ]
oh dude you're right this sounded like
on when i took my sats ah this is a down
[ __ ] this is a
there's a tough one
uh i'm going b
you know i got like an 840 combined
did you and i took a i took a i took a
an s.a.t prep course too
i was supposed to increase your score by
i don't know how many points
to get you into those one of those
schools you know where white kids wear
loafers
all right here we go you ready i'm going
to ride this train
i'm going to go division rival
i'm stupid i'm going to ride this
[ __ ] train i'm going division rival i
am riding the green bay packers
uh aaron rodgers came back looked
phenomenal after that whole covet thing
uh he's playing in minnesota but the
line is only one and a half i'm going to
take green bay minus one and a half oh
i'm taking all points this is set up you
know what's funny paul
my division rivalry thing i think uh
division rivalry and you're getting
points at home i like the vikings plus
one and a half
going head to head paul
oh okay all right
there you go i was sitting there winston
going oh [ __ ] i knew once you said
division rivalry and i knew you loved
the packers i'm like he's not gonna go
he's not gonna go rogue on me and pick
the p and pick the vikings
is that all four are we done i'm done i
think you got one more
oh i got one more all right
i'll tell you what's a weird game that
bills colts
is it ten
that's seven
seven and that carson wentz can [ __ ]
score points is that who those their
quarterback is he can score points the
bills are like they were like covering
everything bills were i was riding the
buffalo train
until the [ __ ] go to jacksonville
yeah then all of a sudden they just
[ __ ] they're not covering and the uh
bill the steelers are actually uh
plus six and a half i think you had said
five and a half just wanna close oh it
is six listeners oh nice i gotta get my
glasses so i have them bro
paul what do you think about that miami
new york jets game what do you think
about that
i was looking at the miami new york jets
it's a division right what are you
helping him out for jesus christ no it's
not help that i just curious what he
thinks all right what do you got i i
just twice he pick miami once i'm
curious sorry i'm a little defensive i'm
almost no no hey listen i've got a gun
to my head here leaning should i take my
new york should i take my new york
giants on monday night football game i
mean that spreads an insult to the
giants that spread is an insult
you're ragging me on you [ __ ] no
who who are they playing
bucks after a bad loss i know and that
they're like a double digit underdog
at home the giants are coming off a bye
no it's in tampa
oh
it's in tampa dude you know what it's
all about in tampa
i mean what do they got in tampa they
got a basic stadium with that stupid
boat they got a ship yeah yeah is it
really like it looks like a [ __ ] you
know
water world place bill you're right
about you're right about the weird game
cults bills but here's another weird one
cardinal seahawks two and a half point
spread two hurt superstar quarterbacks
well i'll tell you right now i'm staying
away from the seahawks i [ __ ] watched
uh
uh what's his face last week throwing he
definitely that finger is messed up he
had some of the worst throws i've seen
of his career
i'm going to take my new york football
giants you know what i've taken them
five times this year and i'm three and
two with them with the spread i'm gonna
take my new york football giants monday
night football coming back from a bye
week saquon barkley back
i think i'm not saying we're going to
win the game but i like the 10 and a
half points i'm going to take the j i'm
going to start that game up 10 points
how about that is it 10 or 10 and a half
it's 10 and a half
but you're i'm almost done dude barkley
could eat up some time on the clock yep
and then your best bet is they go up by
a couple of scores with a few minutes
left and then you get the [ __ ] ball
back
and then they they go down the f dude
how many games i lost this year having
the favorite there's nothing worse than
when the favorites up by two scores with
three minutes left and the other team
gets the [ __ ] ball it's like oh here
they go they're just gonna give up a
touchdown in 90 seconds and there it is
two-point conversion and [ __ ] you
freckles all right that's it all right
that's our picks for the week
that's the picks for the week guys
please remember to go to uh bet mg oh we
got to do a monday night special you got
to do this
monday night special
get some money for you
back i love you
let the monday night special
and by the way i want to tell the
listeners as much as me and bill are in
a competition here
i want us to be 500. like it means a lot
to me you know me oh bill you know i
loved it when we do especially we're
doing the show i love that me and bill
are with the [ __ ] analysts right now
so i don't care so much about analysts
don't pick against the money line do
they no they [ __ ] do i think i mean
against the spread i mean they picked
the money line
oh i lost last week i loved last week
when nate burlson picked the the packers
over the patriots
i love that because when i i did inside
the nfl he gave the patriots a shot for
cheating
so now you know i you know he was just
messing around but i'm like he hates the
patriots this guy hates the patriots
he's a great dude friend of mine great
dude huh
nate pearl's a great dude i just told
you what he said about my home team and
he's still a friend of yours that's how
it is paul
that's your sicilian loyalty
no he was just kidding around but i was
sitting there
him and somebody else both picked the uh
both picked the cleveland browns against
bill belichick in november
dude the i don't even want to get into
the [ __ ] cheating
it's so ridiculous it's such a [ __ ]
well let's not get into it but this
monday night special bill and i want to
let everybody know that me and bill have
done a monday night special four weeks
in a row
and we had two hits in a row 2800 people
one money two weeks ago and then a week
ago
30 something with 3200 people went with
us and we hit that and unfortunately we
did lose we had
two or three out of the we didn't have
the [ __ ] niners we had not gonna win
it every week so that's good it's good
we lost next week so who knows maybe
we're hitting here we're gonna go three
three four four paul
like [ __ ] wade boggs on a matinee way
back in the day but here's the thing
bill here's the thing it's a 10-point
line with the bucks and giants so do we
stay away from the money line
this is a tough one
it's a tough fox and giants oh man i
hate this game mine is 10 and a half
you want to do brady to throw two
well bruce ahrens called him a stupid
football team
yeah so i think they're probably gonna
respond
they did get their butts kicked they're
coming home
saquon barclay's back
coming off a win giants are coming off a
win and defense look pretty good
um
pretty good doesn't cut it if the the
giants are in a wild card hunt and i
think they need this game so
do you want to take the points or no or
do you think that the do you think that
eli was playing this is when you guys
come on i don't know about uh don'ts
what's your guy's name jones
bob jones daniel
daniel dan jones dude bob jones sounds
like a [ __ ] insurance salesman
sounds like a defensive player of the
year for the sixers to me
all right brady g how about this brady
throwing two should we put that in there
or no two touchdowns
yeah all right brady's throwing brady
thrown he throws two okay
um
and it gets difficult oh this is a tough
game you guys usually don't touch the
over under but uh
let's see over under
uh 42 and a half
things a little low it does seem low i
was thinking that's interesting yeah you
know what i think i think i think you go
low
my instinct said to go low
go low
yeah
oh boy all right no because you know why
paul cause that's what everybody [ __ ]
thinks okay you know what
let's do that
i love brady's gonna throw two
touchdowns but the unders coming in this
is a [ __ ] crazy bet
i like it
this just feels to me like one of those
stupid 20 to 17 games
all right pre all right brady to throw
two
under we'll take the under 42
and then what's the third and then 32 oh
42 and a half so 42 okay so 42 we win
all right
and what do you want the third one to be
we need a fun one because i know the
fans like a fun one they like turn over
uh on sidekick
a fake punt
um
dude should we do something wild i mean
this is wild but the money would be huge
and now it's too risky i was going to
say what are you guys going to say is
safety
but that's just too risky because that's
just too risky
dude the money by the time they get a
safety they say that it's on the [ __ ]
half yard line i hate that [ __ ] i know i
know it's forward momentum
um
a fan runs out on the field what's the
line on that oh my god you better win 15
grand if that happens
uh
how about a field goal over 50 yards
49 and a half the over under 49 and a
half oh yeah 49 i love the under okay so
take the 49 and a half i love the under
and i love brady getting two
and um
all right
does uh daniel jones scramble for one
for a touchdown oh
i like it
i like it does he fall down paul is he
gonna cross the goal line oh he's been
he's been running good man i mean i
think if they're at the five he'll do a
bootleg and definitely try to
okay they're at the five he's a short
distance runner that guy
[Laughter]
um
do you want to do that one or do you
that ronnie had looked like me back in
the day when you were drinking in the
woods and you ran from the cops
thank god they scored on that drive
that's all i have to say thank they
scored like two plays later thank god
um
yeah new york quarterbacks man brady two
touchdowns
brady two touchdowns fumbling face
planting oh
remind me of that white guy that dunked
and held onto the rim and then his body
flipped it was it was one
although eli though eli eli saved it
we're not picking no you're not picking
money line winners on this one you want
to just keep it
to the uh
stats
money line winner is just who we think
is going to win the game correct yeah
now you can do i think the [ __ ]
win but i don't i don't know i don't
know that they cover i don't think they
cover
okay
all right so you okay so you want to
take the giants to the money line or
buccaneers i mean
giants i mean buccaneers money line
buccaneers money line only because we
already had that one crazy one of daniel
uh jones russian you gotta have one not
one crazy one okay all right that's it
there we go all four all four you want
so brady two tds under 49 and a half
daniel jones rushing touchdown bucks
money line
yeah [ __ ] it
all right they better pay what does that
pay
uh i'll
calculate it some of this stuff because
they gotta do it uh they got a customer
because all right everybody that's the
monday night special
that's the monday night special guys
[ __ ] weekend goddammit
week 11 is oh my god the nfl is going to
be over soon and it's going to be really
[ __ ] depressing when we're sitting
here talking
hockey and basketball
i'm just kidding
uh uh
you'll have by march madness comes like
a month later
right and then baseball season starts
right
notes you get excited for baseball paul
uh nhl in nba playoffs
i don't know what's going on with me and
baseball i could give a [ __ ] they're
talking about yankee moves and i'm like
whatever dude it's too long of a season
anyway guys go to bed mgm if you want to
get an account i don't think that's what
it is paul have fun with us that's what
it is i think the tide turned you know
you seem to really give a [ __ ]
when you guys were beating the [ __ ] out
of the red sox every year and we were
always choking
now all of a sudden you're losing and
then also oh you know i don't really
care anymore no no i of course i care
but i'm not disappointed paul you know i
finally get a chance to be an obnoxious
sports fan and then you know you just
you take your [ __ ] ball and you go
home
uh what the [ __ ] was i saying yeah bet
mgm guys go to the app use bonus code or
uh bonus code
is that the right bonus code use code
burr b-u-r-r and they're gonna give you
50 bucks on your first bet there you go
have fun with us we have people that
have by the way i was at skankfest a guy
runs up to me and says dude i love this
i love betting with you guys i'm just
having fun there are people that are
just putting 15 20 they're having a good
time sign up go to the monday night
special with us bet mgm is the most
reliable you guys know them the lines
are incredible enjoy the monday night do
it bill the monday night special there
you go over 3000 people jumped on it
last week jump on it this week go go to
bed mgm get the app use bonus code bur
get 50 bucks have a good time we are out
of here guys enjoy nfl week number 11.
you have to be 21 years of age or older
to wager in arizona colorado dc iowa
indianapolis michigan minnesota new
jersey nevada pennsylvania tennessee
virginia west virginia or wyoming only
uh new customer offer paid in free bets
visit bet mgm.com for terms and
conditions
excludes michigan disassociated persons
please gamble responsibly gambling
problem call 1-800 next step for arizona
uh
800-522-4700 for colorado dc nevada
wyoming and virginia
800-270-7117 for confidential help
michigan 1-800 gambler indianapolis new
jersey pennsylvania west virginia 1-800
bets off for iowa call or text the
tennessee red line
800-889-9789 for tennessee or call
888-777-96964 minnesota
sports betting is a void in georgia
hawaii ohio and utah and other states
were prohibited uh promotional offers
not available in nevada
all right that's bet mgm everybody
check them out today and now enjoy the
bonus episode
um of a greatest hits throwback just
before thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast
have a great weekend you cut
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
got me off the
[Music]
any
i
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday november 18 2013.
how the hell are you
how's it going i'm gonna try to [ __ ]
energy my way through the energy
we gotta find ourselves a new kind of
[ __ ] a fool
um i'm wiped out
why are you wiped out bill all you do is
jump around like a [ __ ] monkey on
stage that's what you do for your money
for your legal tender
uh well you know what i've been doing it
in every [ __ ] state in the goddamn
union
this year and i'm wiped out i am
officially wiped the [ __ ] out i had a 6
20 a.m flight out of wichita kansas hey
away did we have ourselves a barn burner
down there last night
and uh landed here at 7 38 on one of
those little ass [ __ ] planes because
nobody goes to wichita not directly
anyways
so i was on a little ass plane we landed
in the little last plane and you know
what happens to little last planes they
don't get to pull up to the gate oh
you're too small you're going to hurt
yourself little ass plane
so we're sitting out there on the
[ __ ] topic
right this is an old-school plane they
tried to paint it like a new united
plane but they still had the u
that was from um
you know like the 70s it was a [ __ ]
old-ass plane okay
i don't know if they took it over the
gas monkey garage and they put a new
[ __ ] engine in it i don't know what
but we made it but it was one of those
deals where they open the door and the
stairs are part of the [ __ ] door
so we walk out of that
and then we get on the goddamn plane
playing a bus the bus to the [ __ ]
airport the airport then the bags came
out [ __ ] so i am uh
but you know something
i completed the red state tour
all right it was supposed to be a nice
wonderful
summer jaunt
through the red states of this country
through some of them
by the way there's a lot of people
giving me [ __ ] going nebraska's a red
state too i always a red state's a
[ __ ] red state you know what go [ __ ]
yourself okay i got something for you
i got something for you [ __ ] out there
who keep giving me [ __ ] why don't you
[ __ ] come to mind what do you got
against my [ __ ] state
what do you got against coming to one of
my i've been in over 50 cities
50 goddamn cities i don't know what else
i'm supposed to do to try to find you
[ __ ]
all right
you want to hear want to hear a quick
little rundown
you want to know what all these cities
have in common honolulu seattle boise
bozeman san francisco san jose los
angeles burbank coachella palm springs
napa valley santa wines phoenix las
vegas boulder colorado springs deadwood
el paso san antonio austin dallas
minneapolis madison milwaukee grand
rapids royal oak chicago kansas city st
louis indianapolis cincinnati cleveland
buffalo pittsburgh huntsville morgantown
philadelphia atlantic city red bank new
york city montville newport hyannis
boston hampton beach washington d.c
charleston atlanta athens birmingham
tallahassee tampa and miami
and tulsa and [ __ ] wichita you know
what they all have in common i [ __ ]
dance like a monkey there for an hour
so if i didn't hit you stay to your city
i don't know what the [ __ ] else i got to
do i'm
i'm wiped out as they say in oklahoma
whapped
i was watching their local um
well at the shopping network
you know those things where like the
husband's out working or something and
the wife gets like addicted and just has
to buy those diameters or whatever and
they had this cross and she goes now
look at this this is genuine
white gold just kept going white
right
white gold
whites only
hey guess where the racism's from
white's only dope that's boston
right what only that's tulsa oklahoma
at least that's where i watched it
and then lastly whites only
that's a gay guy at a
i'm laundromat
it's a bad joke [ __ ] you i'm tired
don't get the white don't get the whites
messed in with the colors
um
anyways
whatever this podcast is going to suck
but maybe it's going to be enjoyable
because of how much it sucks uh
yeah i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
going to talk about this week uh let's
get let's get right into a little bit
of uh my tour
i just called 15 audibles as i was
saying that dragging that sentence out
let's get into a little by the way you
know right now i'm not supposed to be
doing this podcast i'm supposed to be
talking to somebody from reykjavik and i
got to tell you iceland well the first
guy had water damage i called them up it
sounded like it just happened so we're
rescheduling that one and then the other
dude at 10 30
i don't know what happened man
i'm sitting here on the other side of
the world eagerly awaiting your phone
call and what do i get i get nothing
you know what somebody told me when i go
over to that beautiful country of
iceland
you know
that country that stood up to the
bankers
that country that i can't wait to go see
somebody said it smells like sulfur
because of that uh that volcanic
eruption there volcanic the volcano
eruption
uh remember that one that blocked all
the flights
to and from europe a few years ago it
still smells like sulfur over there and
uh
i don't know i think that's kind of
[ __ ] cool
to be that close to a live volcano
um i can't [ __ ] that's one of the
ones i'm really looking forward to that
because uh
on that trip over there that's the
country i haven't been to yet so i don't
give a [ __ ] what it smells like i heard
the women are beautiful
uh they stuck up to the banks and they
[ __ ] live right next to a volcano and
they don't give a [ __ ] so thumbs up to
iceland i can't wait to go
and i think i'm actually going to get to
see the northern lights
you know stand there with a little tear
in my eye wondering why humanity can't
get along
um
so anyways i i did uh the rest of the
red state tours
uh dates and um
you know i know it was crazy as far as
like it didn't come off the way i
thought it was going to but i honored
every [ __ ] date and i added san
antonio
all right we made them happen el paso
took three times to get to
three trips
one time i cancelled because i'm a
little twinkle toes doing my acting work
the next time it got rained out and then
finally we made it happen and i got some
angry emails but in the end we made it
happen so anyway so i go to deadwood
south dakota in the black hills the
western part of south dakota and uh i
had a [ __ ] awesome time highly
recommend it
i went and i actually saw mount rushmore
scratch that off the bucket list um
and i highly recommend that you go
during
the winter months
because i could just tell it would be
[ __ ] packed
with a bunch of goddamn breeders with
their [ __ ]
jean cut off shorts
as i was walking up all the stairs and
nobody was on it
that nobody was on i could just i said
to the guy who brought us over there i
was like dude this place is packed in
the summertime he's like oh yeah man
it's awful it's awful so go there in the
winter nice crisp air or whatever the
fall whatever [ __ ] season we're in right
now that's the time to go toughen up
your [ __ ] kids
pull them out of school
and bring them there all right
start up the winnebago once over the
winter or in the fall
get the thing up there i'm telling you
it's great we did the whole goddamn
thing in like 20 minutes you know what's
great as you come up the hill i'm
literally miming this with my hand like
driving my hand towards my face in case
i forget what it's like to drive up a
hill as you're driving up a hill
you come up
all the way up the mountain there right
or the hill i guess
and uh all you see you just look out and
i swear to god you can see all the way
to wyoming and you're like what the [ __ ]
where is it and then you just come
around a turn and the way they do it is
so [ __ ] cool
they show you what the four presidents
are looking at
and then you turn around and you're like
holy [ __ ] there it is like a goddamn
horror movie
you know you think the guy's behind the
curtain and he's not there and you're
like oh good yeah you relax you let out
that exhale you turn around jesus christ
four dead presidents
you know
and you know for the life of me i always
wondered why they picked those four not
even those four why teddy roosevelt
you know i understood mo larry and curly
but i didn't get shemp why the [ __ ] is
he up there
you know
i didn't understand it was another good
reference
okay david lee roth sammy hagar and then
that dude from that that band
if you don't like what we do here get
the funk out get the [ __ ] out get the
[ __ ] out get the [ __ ] out shut up
what
would you do
oh my god i never want to drag somebody
down the [ __ ] stairs by their
ponytails
as much as when that [ __ ] song came
on
um
anyways teddy roosevelt i asked the guy
there why did they why teddy i don't see
the [ __ ] connection here
it's like a bad stand-up tour where you
get three styles that mesh and then just
one guy has got i don't know a [ __ ]
ukulele
and i guess they were all responsible
for the expansion
expansionism
of this country george washington
because he helped us uh with our
conspiracy theory not theory our
conspiracy to [ __ ] leave the goddamn
uh
english empire
all right which started it
it's not really expanding that's sort of
separating but who the [ __ ] am i
uh
thomas jefferson louisiana purchase
oh my god i'm gonna forget who else is
there oh abe lincoln abraham
a trey as his friends called him uh
because he held the union together
um
and then teddy roosevelt because he uh
was brutally racist
and was able to uh
kick all the mexicans out of the western
part of this country
you know that's a really weird part i
got to tell you this really weird part
of the country uh south dakota
absolutely [ __ ] beautiful
but it's kind of like
i feel like what germany would look like
if the germans won
the way history is told
you know what i mean
i mean
that is you're basically
on uh holocaust ground out there
but because
you know
the [ __ ] evil doers won
just the way it's you know
you can go visit custer's last stand
and they have like you know grave sites
for all these [ __ ] mass murdering
psychopaths
but you know
they won
so it's all like done yeah
so like basically if hitler and those
[ __ ] maniacs won there would be a
mount rushmore in germany it would be
hitler
it'd be uh who's that guy heimlich
himmler whatever the [ __ ] his name is
basically his scottie pippen
right and they have a couple other all
those [ __ ] evil nazi dudes
i don't know where they would be facing
but whatever that doesn't mean you
shouldn't go out there it's absolutely
[ __ ] beautiful and i had a great time
performing at the casino i met some real
live cowboys real life cowboys got
invited to go back to a ranch next time
i'm out there for some quick draw
shooting with [ __ ] wax bullets what'd
you do this [ __ ] weekend
i already asked them i go what do you
mean wax we just like shoot them at each
other and they're like laughing like oh
no you shoot them into a target i go
what happens if you get hit with one
they got stings it's not that big a deal
so in my head i just started laughing
because i was like all right back in the
day me and my knucklehead friends if we
got waxed bullets and they're not going
to kill you we're going to put on
swimming goggles possibly a scuba mask
and you know within 20 minutes we're
going to be [ __ ] shooting at each
other
um
and i guess if you go there in the
summertime
you see bald eagles out there like
they're pigeons
so that's another reason to come back
what i'm saying is i'm definitely coming
back to deadwood i had a [ __ ]
phenomenal phenomenal time
and uh
learned a little bit about american
history and that type of stuff and uh
then the next day i had an early flight
i flew down to tulsa oklahoma
and i had no idea what to expect we
drove into town me and lucas now you
seely now you don't
lucasily um
his football nickname that never
happened
they called him the orient express i
believe
or the asian invasion i forget what he
grew up in montana he's like one of
three asians out there so the white
people didn't know any better
um
so
what am i saying here so we're going to
[ __ ] tulsa and it's like uh
i don't know it's like a zombie movie
there's like nobody there
it's windy as [ __ ] hell because
there's nothing to stop the goddamn wind
and i asked the guy i'm like dude we
pull up to the hotel it was like creepy
it wasn't even like homeless people it
was like nothing we're driving into town
stopping at red lights and it's green
for the other way and there's no cars
the only thing was missing was like
tumbleweeds
so we pull in there
and i asked the guy
when i parked the car i'm like where the
hell where the hell is everybody he's
like ah you know it gets kind of dead
here on the weekends
but at night it totally picked up
and it ended up being this awesome
[ __ ] city and we performed at this
place called uh
uh [ __ ] the brady theater
an old vaudeville theater that was
finished in 1916 and it was one of the
coolest places i've ever performed in
and it was just an absolutely [ __ ]
awesome crowd
just had a great time and uh
i don't know and you know the usual [ __ ]
harry houdini performed here and it's
[ __ ] haunted and all of that crap can
you feel me running out of gas everybody
i'm running out of gas dude
i've traveled too much this [ __ ] year
i'm sorry let's try to let's try to ramp
up the god damn comedy i can't nothing
funny happened in tulsa i just had a
great [ __ ] time and there was a guy
uh
the runner
this guy ray who worked at a 1960
cadillac in the end of the the
all original
the end of the show i'm driving this
thing around tulsa 1960 [ __ ] cadillac
having a great time then we went to this
german bar
which was a good time but i got to tell
you there was a little bit too much
wiener schnitzel if you know what i mean
i was trying to be a wingman for my
buddy
and there was nothing to talk to there
right
and uh
i don't know then the next day we drove
up from tulsa to wichita and i got to
tell you something about the drive from
tulsa to wichita i would not work i
would not wish that on my worst [ __ ]
enemy
it was one of the worst drives
the absolute the opposite of driving
through the black hills in south dakota
that is one that you can skip
there was [ __ ]
nothing nothing
unless you're out there looking for some
classic cars and that type of [ __ ]
um
i you know i swear to god it's like
every other [ __ ] house out there has
some [ __ ] car you're like holy [ __ ]
you know that's a mustang
look at that there's an old [ __ ] ford
pickup truck every guy it seems like
every other house i'm exaggerating but
there was probably like i saw probably
like 20
cars on the way up and trucks and then
there was a whole
you know i don't know this one guy had
like [ __ ] 30 of the old things up
there i just started thinking of that
that uh fast and loud that they should
just drive that uh raptor up there and
[ __ ] somehow talk those people into
selling their cars for 40 bucks
uh then we got into wichita wichita was
uh a little creepy i'm not gonna lie to
you a little creepy
i missed my term we came into the back
part of the [ __ ] town and now we went
by the rehab clinic
and uh really saw that drugs touch
everybody
[Laughter]
it looked like a [ __ ] old
like if they did a real world reunion
episode and everybody was in their 50s
that's what it looked like there was the
old white guy the old black guy an old
asian guy
an old latino dude just all [ __ ]
standing out there a couple of [ __ ]
haggard looking chicks
you know looking like retired witches
and
we played at the orpheum there where
like the count basie orchestra played
gracie george burns grace allen uh
gracie allen whatever they had played
there just [ __ ] insane um absolutely
awesome shows and uh
you know i want to thank everybody who
came out i'm definitely coming back i'm
definitely going to do that run and next
time i come back i'm going to add
nebraska
and uh i don't know what else i got to
go to out there maybe iowa but whatever
i feel like i uh put my foot down out
there
left my footprint
i got another place another uh tour i
can do
when i get old and gray or whatever it's
all good [ __ ] all right i'm just [ __ ]
meandering here let's let's do a little
advertising
uh where the [ __ ] are we here
and then i'm gonna ramp it back up
talking about that [ __ ] [ __ ] call
against the 49ers and pete carroll's
twitter message all right i'm teasing
you here
that's a little teaser all right dollar
shave club everybody
let's see if i can shave a couple of
strokes off my [ __ ] bad reading all
right this how it works every week with
the advertising
whatever
whatever mistakes i make on the first
one that's par for the course and i just
try to see if i can go under all right
here we go dollar shave club everyone
for a couple of bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your door not
only does it save you a ton of cash it
saves you from trudging your pathetic
ass down to the drugstore for a pack of
blades i don't know about you guys but i
always get stuck behind that lady paying
with all her loose change from the car
ashtray stroke number one it's like she
thinks exact change is a
requirement i'm not a patient person but
you know i try to be patient with old
people
but it's like dude i came in with scruff
now i'm leaving with a beard
uh but now for dollar shave but now with
dollar shave club two
now with all the shave club for a couple
bucks a month amazing quality razor
blades are delivered right to your front
door that's right no more wasting time
and no more getting hit up for 20 bucks
every time you buy razors everybody here
is getting their dollar shave club
blades and you should too and here's a
genius idea try replacing your old
shaving cream with dr carver's easy
shave butter from
dollarshaveclub.com trust me your face
will thank you later uh don't waste time
at the drugstore behind the lady paying
at pennies go to
dollarshaveclub.comforwardslashburr
or go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner keep your
stress level low and your bank account
balance high save time shave money go to
dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash burr
all right there you go so two strokes is
par here we go
i'm feeling good
failing feeling this one all right hulu
plus you've probably tried hulu.com now
with hulu plus you can watch your
favorite shows anytime anywhere hulu
plus lets you watch thousands of hit tv
shows and a selection of acclaimed
movies on your television or on the go
with your smartphone or tablet and it
all streams in hd for the best viewing
experience possible with hulu plus you
can watch your favorite current tv shows
like saturday night live community and
family guy you can also check out
exclusive content including hulu
originals like the awesomes
starring seth meyers and moonboy
starring chris o'dowd from bridesmaids
hulu plus also offers a great selection
of acclaimed films for only 7.99 a month
you can stream as many tv shows and
movies as you want wherever you want
right now you can try hulu plus for free
for two weeks when you go to
huluplus.com
bill that's a special offer for my
listeners make sure you use huluplus.com
so you get extended free trial
the extended free trial and they know we
send you sent you damn it one over go to
huluplus.com bill now or click the hulu
plus banner on the podcast page at
billboard.com god damn it i thought i
had it
all right
what do we got left here all right let's
try one more
i gotta break par here one of these ones
can i can i have one flawless one do you
believe in me
here we go
vista print
vistaprint is a small business bet uh
jesus christ [ __ ] that that's a mulligan
i'm doing it again
vista print
vista print is a small businesses best
friend
most everything a small business needs
for printing is available at vistaprint
personalized iphone cases available from
vistaprint.com
easily design your own iphone case to
match your multi-faceted life whether
it's personal or business whether it's a
family photo team logo company logo your
wedding your last vacation or even just
personal message you can easily create
your own iphone case at vistaprint.com
prices as low as 14.99 if you own a
small business order iphone cases for
you and your employees with your company
name and logo on it
prospective clients will notice
great way to get your company's name out
there give them give them away as
company gifts unlimited possibilities
vista print affordable quality marketing
and printing products for small
businesses
please talk about your experience with
vistaprint well i find your
i find your copy to be very choppy and
difficult to read
all right i think i said vistaprint too
many times
uh all iphone cases are 25 off for my
listeners come on man this is a great
deal here all right
if you have a damn bit let's fail with
the copy if you have a business right
you got everybody out in the field if
they walk around they got the name right
on the little cell phone cover they walk
into a bar they strike up a conversation
with a lady
all right it's good advertising i
believe in this product i just have no
use for it
i'm a one-man band here
all iphone cases are 25 off for my
listeners and get free shipping on
your entire order if you spend more than
30 bucks just go to vistaprint.com click
on the text link in the upper right hand
corner type in the promo code bird
that's vistaprint and click on the text
link in the upper right hand corner type
in the promo code bur satisfaction
guaranteed not happy they'll make it
right no risk like old school american
companies they'll make it right
okay there you go jesus christ brutal
reading
that was like a public course right
there a bunch of [ __ ] divots
all right here we where do i start this
week
nfl pro football did anybody watch the
49ers versus the saints
now i am impartial i actually like the
saints i did that movie down there and i
had a great [ __ ] time and i was i was
really getting into the saints and i
think their fans are awesome and that
type of thing i also like the 49ers so i
like both of them i like both coaches i
like both quarterbacks i like those
teams
so i watch the game and i got to tell
you the 49ers got robbed
and i'm not blaming the saints and i
don't expect saint fans to have any
empathy but you know god damn well if
the shoe was on the other foot you'd be
like what the [ __ ]
okay
[ __ ] the saints [ __ ] the 49ers let's
just talk football here what exactly
was that guy supposed to do when he was
trying to tackle drew brees what exactly
was he what the [ __ ] is he supposed to
do
drew brees is playing at full speed so
on defense you're supposed to go what
three quarter speed when the game is on
the line it wasn't a helmet to helmet
hit
he didn't [ __ ] you know it wasn't an
attack on a defenseless player whatever
the hell they call it
he's trying to run around the outside to
get to drew brees he's got the [ __ ]
outside goddamn lineman whatever the
[ __ ] it is pushing him to the outside
he's going by the quarterback he reaches
out to grab him
and in the process
he catches him in the neck a little bit
and the guy goes down it's a violent
[ __ ] game
right
last year you couldn't hit him in the
head now you can't hit quarterbacks in
the top in the head or in the [ __ ]
neck
what are they going to be able to do
next year i think next year when you go
to tackle a quarterback you ever going
to put like a sheet on a bed and you do
like that
kind of thing and then it
goes and lands on the bed what does it
do bill it goes
i think that's what you're gonna have to
do
the 49ers needed somebody to step up and
make a [ __ ] play and that guy made
the play he caused a [ __ ] turnover
and he recovered the ball game over
all right but because of today's game
they took it away from him
and then they end up losing the game
that was a textbook play it was [ __ ]
beautiful play
i mean you could sit there and watch
lawrence taylor highlights and he has a
zillion of those
he used to he's to just bull rush people
reach over them grab the quarterback by
his shirt and just drag him down to the
ground
i i just you can't [ __ ] do anything
anymore and uh
i don't know i don't know if it's
because i've been watching football too
long that to me that looks like football
and now they're saying it isn't
i obviously like most of you probably
saw that interview with tony dorsett and
i hate seeing that type of stuff i don't
want former football players
to be like that but jesus christ
he didn't get a concussion nothing that
you know i i found really interesting
was troy aikman thought it was a good
call and howie long was just shaking his
head for those of you who don't watch
football troy aikman's a former
quarterback
and how he longs at former defensive uh
tackler and i forget what position he
played so
it's drew brees didn't get hurt
he didn't have a concussion he was fine
he got right up troy aikman's going oh
look you can see his lips bloody well
he's playing football
you know
the [ __ ]
so i think the 49ers got [ __ ]
i don't know what the solution is the i
maybe have to go back to leather helmets
i have no idea but jesus chris you got
to be able to reach out grab the [ __ ]
quarterback as you go down yeah and
maybe sometime he goes down a little bit
violently
i mean
i don't [ __ ] know
somebody on my twitter account was like
laughing going like next year they're
going to treat quarterbacks like kickers
like if you even touch them
it's an automatic unnecessary roughness
now that he definitely went down in a
rough way but it's a tough game
but he's fine if he has any sort of
[ __ ]
problems at the 20 years after he
retires it's not going to be because of
that hit i could have taken that [ __ ]
hit i'm not going to lie to you i'd feel
the effects for three weeks but i could
have taken that hit and gotten up and
thrown a [ __ ]
goddamn duck the next play i could have
done that
and i am a stand-up comedian if i could
have taken the [ __ ] hit
all right
[ __ ] you i could have but most of you
could have too you could have taken it
jesus christ i've gotten a hit harder
than that plane [ __ ]
killed a man with the ball back in the
day or whatever you guys called the game
that's what we called it kill the man
with the ball
murder the [ __ ]
um
and then lastly the last thing i'm going
to say about the [ __ ] football this
week was uh pete carroll's
uh former team that he coached usc beat
um
i almost said syracuse so [ __ ] tired
beat stanford
which was a major upset and um
stanford had beaten usc like four years
in a row so it was a big victory for
them
and uh
so pete carroll tweeted you know
basically a congrat congratulations
to usc which is [ __ ] hilarious and
then espn shows it they all blah blah
blah blah and at no point do they
discuss how pete carroll
you know peter left that team high and
dry
or maybe that's just part of the
arrangement that college football
coaches have because i don't begrudge
the guy what he did he did what
everybody has to do to win at a division
one level as you break a bunch of
[ __ ] rules and then years later they
make a movie about it called blue chips
with [ __ ] nick nolte
right
um
or north dallas floyd came out the
[ __ ] movie was called
i don't know
i just thought it was funny that he
writes back to the school that he left
high and dry as he sat there telling
every all those incoming freshmen that
he was going to develop him and they'd
have an nfl [ __ ] career and then all
of a sudden death's at the back door and
he just [ __ ] takes off and goes up to
seattle
you know i don't think that thing really
had anything that tweet had anything to
do with usc i think that had to do with
his [ __ ] hatred of uh captain come
back there in the time he ran up to
score when he was coaching [ __ ] uh
syracuse right jim harbaugh i think it
had more to do with that
um
but i was disappointed that the end of
his
his tweet didn't say
hashtag um all right
where are we how many [ __ ] minutes in
are we can i start reading shot jesus 29
30 minutes
30 [ __ ] minutes what am i going to do
here
what are we going to talk about the
green piece 30 again nothing has changed
as far as i can tell
far as i can oh oh one more thing about
the [ __ ] uh football is verzi's new
york football giants won again
and uh
i don't i don't dislike the giants i
actually love the giants
um
just as a franchise right even though
they beat the patriots i i get i get
beyond that they beat the patriots what
the [ __ ] were they supposed to do lose
to them you know they're trying to win
the game and they want it
good for them i don't give a [ __ ] but
what it is is with every victory they
have
i'm gonna have to listen to versi going
on
and on
just fast forward 20 minutes into this
podcast because i'm still going to be
going on and on and he's still talking
about robinson canal
like this is what you have to know about
paul verzi
he likes gum he bears
he likes going to the movies
and he spends a hundred percent of his
time when he's talking about sports
talking about the ten percent of the
time that he was actually right and it
drives me up the [ __ ] wall you know
one of his predictions was was the
patriots were crazy not to resign matt
castle
i [ __ ] nailed that one
i've already talked i've talked about
this one a million times i give up i
give up with this guy i called the
[ __ ] super bowl this year and i put
my money down
i never brought it up to him
he's already talking about he's already
sending me text messages
this is what kills me like when i call
something i'm like all right i got lucky
verzi actually thinks
that something like paranormal happened
that he has like esp
like when he caught when he calls
something he's got this thing where he
kind of puts his head down he's like
looking through his eyebrows
you know he gets he gets a little crazy
that guy is not all there
don't buy into his little [ __ ]
you know when you when you get the paul
versi brochure
in the mail when he's coming to your
town i'm telling you that guy
he's not all there
i'm just [ __ ] with you i love the guy
you know this is why i love paul verzi
all right there's a zillion reasons but
i have to get back to him i had a quick
phone call and i was going i figured
what the [ __ ] i was doing i was i think
i was going in i was gonna do a show
and he called me up to talk to me about
a veal chop he just ate
you know
it's just [ __ ] hilarious
how much he's into food it's ridiculous
oh anyways this week everybody
i got a couple of all things comedy
um our wonderful new podcast network
um that i have to tell you about uh me
and al madrigal
the daily shows and minivan men podcast
al madrigal are going to be hosting a
garage sale shale a garage sale
um both of us have taken [ __ ] out of our
garages and our lives our lives i can't
even talk we're taking stuff out of our
garages and our lives
comedy memorabilia
old hockey sticks i got one of those
[ __ ] man great systems that they sent
me they already gave me one
you know what am i supposed to stack two
on top of each other i don't even think
the meat would cook at that point those
things are so thick so i got one of
those
uh what else do i got i got a i got some
[ __ ] old
why do i do this let it go
uh dvds that all be autographed
i got this [ __ ] trunk
metal locker trunk thing that the last
people owned my house left in the garage
you know i don't know what al's bringing
but uh
you know i'm sure he's got a bunch of
stuff too and uh all of the proceeds are
gonna go towards the wounded warrior
project
um also
uh there's another all things comedy um
show down at largo here in los angeles
down in la cienega just north of beverly
i'm going to be 8 o'clock this wednesday
i will be performing there as well as a
bunch of other
hosts of podcasts on our network please
come down
have a good time learn about our network
and um
what else
um oh also i got to give a shout out to
the occasionally awesome podcast
hosted by kevin christie and nick
youssef two phenomenal younger comics
they're young to me all right they're
probably young to you
but uh and also if you think i love dogs
you gotta listen to kevin christie dude
that guy is like i'm swear to god
i think if you pet his dog in the wrong
direction like a cat you'd probably be
missing a limb
and he would never apologize and that's
why i love him but anyways they gave me
a nice shout out
um
they had max greenfield
on their podcast from the new girl and i
guess he talked about um
that episode i did where
he's basically sticking his head in a
coffin with a dead body there and i'm
trying to get him to stop doing it
because i'm trying to take a gold chain
off the dead body
it was [ __ ] hilarious we i think we
shot it at one in the morning and he had
me laugh in my i had such a great time
doing that show
between working with max
and uh
working with nick kroll
and all my scenes i swear to god it
seemed like they were one in the morning
and i was feeling like i was gonna pass
out and that i can't hack it as an actor
and both of them had me laughing my ass
off at what in the morning a stand-up
comic who doesn't laugh at [ __ ]
so uh
anyways so check out the occasionally uh
awesome
on the all things comedy network and
there you go there's a little mini
commercial there
let me go back to the uh
go back to uh rambling here so basically
because i don't want to listen to versi
you know and he's one dumb [ __ ]
prediction his duel i think is the only
thing that he's actually going to get
right this year and we're in november
as far as i know i don't know anything
else he said right this year he was
wrong about the super bowl
he was wrong about that christmas
sweater that he wore the last time we
worked together this is going to be the
first ah you know what everybody's right
every every once in a while
jesus he's going to i guaran [ __ ] it
2016 i'm still going to be hearing about
this yeah what about that [ __ ]
giant's prediction you know
um
so he's actually made me like an eagles
fan like i'm rooting for the [ __ ] i'm
rooting for somebody in that goddamn
division to actually win
some [ __ ] games
okay philadelphia eagles dallas cowboys
[ __ ] redskins i'm done with you
all right but it's not too late all
three of you
the giant spotted you six
[ __ ] games
all right this is
this is inexcusable
for you to let those [ __ ] come back and
win the [ __ ] division absolutely
[ __ ]
inexcusable they're not [ __ ] i love the
giants i actually like the [ __ ]
giants
i just don't want to listen to versi for
the love of god philadelphia eagles
dallas cowboys next week when you play
the [ __ ] giants can you play full
four quarters
you know
don't do it for yourselves do it for me
oh my god
jesus christ
he is gonna go on for [ __ ] ever
um all right let's read some [ __ ] here
uh dollar shave club correction this is
from a listener hey bill can you change
that copy to read rusty soup can instead
of rusty soda can
aluminum aluminum soda cans don't rust
but the tin coated soup cans sure as
hell will
i honestly want it to be helpful
i can try to break your balls another
time thanks for the podcast that's
[ __ ] hilarious is there any time is
anything better when somebody's just
like
scientifically correct
you know
i didn't know that aluminum cans don't
rust i had no idea
i didn't even know the cans were made
out of aluminum
i didn't know what it was i thought it
was some sort of
you know some sort of metal plastic kind
of [ __ ] i know i didn't know what it was
i never knew what it was all right how
to handle conspiracy theories
billy bankbuster oh by the [ __ ] way
wait a second
wait a minute i forgot to bring this up
do you guys know
that one of my fantasies is coming true
this week
no it's not reading copy correctly
uh
there's two bankers being put to death
in vietnam
let me look this up here
death vietnam
vietnamese bankers sentenced to death
for fraud
here we go
this is what this is what should have
been happening in this country in 2008
like
it already should have like
they should have been at least 100
bankers dead
you know what you should do is like
smother them with cash
[Laughter]
now what you do is you tie them to the
mast of their yacht or their sailboat
right
and then you put a bunch of cash at
their feet all the cash that they stole
you just light it on fire
right like jonah [ __ ] it up
um
let me see if i can find where the [ __ ]
is it
here we go yahoo free news let's go here
a vietnamese former banker and his
business associates have been sentenced
to death for their part in the
embezzlement of 25 million dollars
state media has reported 25 million
bucks and you get the goddamn death
sentence
all right
so i figured that the people at aig they
ought to have like what happened to
william wallace at the end of braveheart
whatever that [ __ ] thing is
well they just pull out your [ __ ]
entrails
like machete
um the pair were among 11 defendants
in the nine-day trial in ho chi minh
city
state media reported on saturday in a
case that has heightened vietnam's
effort to show it is stamping out
corruption in the face of widespread
public anger over the issue that's the
only part of this story i don't like
uh the fact that they're trying to make
an example so now i think that they just
got a couple of ollie north here they're
going to kill two people
or 11 and be like see we're doing
something and then it goes right back
now i don't know what politicians make
in vietnam but if it's anything like
over here you know the bankers put them
in office so i have no [ __ ] idea but
anyways this is the deal
vu quoc howl
58 the one-time chief of the finance
subsidiary subsidiary of the state-owned
vietnam agribank and building firm boss
dang van hai
56 were sentenced to death on friday
according to state television they were
given the sentence for embezzlement of
assets mismanagement abuse of power and
fraud causing serious consequences to
the state sound familiar everybody i
just did that when i hated last week
sound familiar
um the other nine defendants were jailed
for up to 14 years for violating state
economic regulations the report added
the group was accused of embezzling more
than 25 million dollars of state money
between april 2008 and march 2009 by
falsifying financial leasing contracts
according to reports on state media
vietnam is rated one of the world's most
corrupt nations
and graft is a top concern for many
ordinary people the communist government
has vowed to clap down on the issue
there will be strict punishment for
state uh
i'm not gonna read the rest of this [ __ ]
i'll spare you guys i read it pretty
well up to that point
um
so there you go
there you go see that it doesn't matter
what kind of government you have
a democracy communism socialism
dictatorship the [ __ ] bankers are
running [ __ ] and they need to be put
down in the [ __ ] street
and replaced with honest people
you know like some of those
fine folks that i met out there in the
hot land
that would be great i would actually go
to the execution
as [ __ ] morbid as that is
you know
i would actually go there
who the [ __ ] is sitting there texting me
now um
all right let's go back to the uh
why did i just drop my voice
let's go back to the uh questions for
this week how to handle conspiracy
theories billy bankbuster i'm all in
when it comes to reading and researching
ideas independent
of those we hear all day in the media
whether it be the banks the lizard
people or the fact that we live in a
simulation it's all important
information i'm with you when it comes
to shrugging off a particular air of
pretentiousness like that guy in the
human farming video the problem with
general reaction to new information is
that everyone
does that i'm a democrat
uh i'm a republican [ __ ]
where they just pick a side and defend
it to death here's the truth
all in capital letters the truth is is
that there's some truth to the fact that
we are being pushed around by those in
power
well who the [ __ ] are you to say that
this is the truth why can't you say this
is your version of the truth you came at
me all diplomatic i was really liking
who you are and then all of a sudden you
yelled at me out of nowhere
you lulled me in i was right there
here's the truth
the truth is that there is some truth to
the fact that we're being pushed around
by those in power it's true that people
in power have bigger plans that we
that we know about
we know this because it's been that way
forever it takes the current population
so long to get over their emotional
reaction to finding out negative things
that by the time they understand
everything they're dead and their kids
are voting for the next jackass i agree
with the way you handle this stuff
you're in but you're not letting it ruin
your life this is a revolution of
knowledge that can't be stopped now
please run for office and stay out of
convertibles
all right i'm such a defensive [ __ ] i
thought you were disagreeing with me
until right in the end um no there's no
[ __ ] way
i'm too goddamn dumb
and i've jerked off to too much [ __ ]
horrific [ __ ] on the internet and uh
i you know
that doesn't mean that i i couldn't be
in office i would just have to be a
company player you know i really got to
start reading up on this [ __ ] guy up
in toronto man
this crack smoking [ __ ] eating [ __ ]
mayor whatever they got up there
somebody was somebody was trying to tell
me uh
i'm literally looking up toronto mayor
eating [ __ ]
rob ford denies eating [ __ ] video
he denies that he ate this woman's [ __ ]
he said he's married and has plenty to
eat at home
and then walked off
you know like he just dropped the mic
that's the greatest [ __ ] thing ever
you got to love that kind of honesty
what the [ __ ] is this
is this somebody piggybacking on this
thing
oh jesus is this a commercial i have to
sit through i just hit mute
all right here we go
the last thing was um olivia gonda that
says that i want to eat her [ __ ] they
let her conduct i've never said that in
my life to her i would never do that i'm
happily married i've got more than
enough to eat at home thank you very
much
[Laughter]
dude did he just have a [ __ ] jersey
with his name on it in the back this guy
is the [ __ ] greatest thing ever
hang on hang on wait a minute then
there's a flabbergasted lady
[Music]
mayor ford
speaking as mayor ford does
[Laughter]
you know what
i don't know if he was born that way or
smoking crack gives you some balls this
guy just doesn't give a [ __ ]
i don't know anything about this story
it's only what i've heard i don't know
if you're if you're in office for life
but uh
if he smokes crack the way i drink booze
i don't think it's gonna affect his job
you know if he just has a couple two or
three cracks
at the end of the day you like smoke and
crack
that's you know something there's just
something
you got to go down swinging in life
right
that's the way to go down because he
knows eventually it's like if i'm gonna
get squeezed out [ __ ] it dude the guy
had a jersey with his name on it with
the number on the back i don't know what
the [ __ ] that was about but um
whatever he's owned by the banks too you
might as well have somebody entertaining
isn't that right cleo
oh cleo
oh you were sleeping i'm sorry buddy
how are you doing
my [ __ ] dog is hilarious i came on an
early flight right and i come home
right and i'd pull up to the house or
whatever and i come in
and she didn't know i was coming home
now she has no i have no one coming home
she has no concept of me leaving i just
walk out the door and she hasn't she
doesn't know i'm going to wichita
what kind of a [ __ ] stupid sentence
was that
well it was what you were thinking bill
um
so i walk in and she hates hardwood
floors she just feels like she can't get
any sort of balance on them so she has
to walk really slow with their head down
so i come in and she hears the door
unlocking so she comes running out and
she knows it's me and she's all excited
but she's walking on hardwood floors so
she was walking really slowly while her
tail was wagging 90 miles an hour and
her [ __ ] shaking her pitbull booty
like walking sideways
it's one of the best laughs if you don't
have a dog you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
what does a cat do well maybe a cat does
something because i have never didn't
grow up with cats what is a cat too that
is like
similar to that i remember i dated this
girl and she had a cat she had a cool
one
and i would [ __ ] wake up in the
morning this thing would be standing
on my chest
like doing that thing you know where
they're sort of like like they're trying
to pull your shirt apart
that used to make me laugh
but um
i just don't like that they [ __ ] inside
you know it's in that goddamn box
it smells like i don't know
there's just no appreciation from maybe
i'm too needy to be a cat owner
i respect cats so
you know they're in the deal but not of
it
and they also retain their hunting
skills they keep those polished i think
that they know that the dollar is going
to crash the way they always go out and
[ __ ] kill mice and stuff
um all right here we go
where is it here advice my mom thinks
she's a psychic
uh hey big red
long time fan and loyal follower of the
mm podcast for the past five years can't
wait for the new podcast t-shirts i'm
picking them up today
oh was it a journey with this [ __ ]
company
jesus christ it took forever
forever for [ __ ] ever we changed the
design a couple times and then you know
and then from then on i don't know what
the [ __ ] happened
um anyways he said i need your advice on
how to bring my 58 year old mom back to
reality ever since my mom's menopause my
brother and i came to the realization
that my mom believes she has the ability
to speak and see those whom
whom have crossed over to the other side
this has to do with her menopause
i don't i don't think
i think you're looking at the wrong
answer
she even has no problems pushing her
beliefs onto complete strangers
for example
i was having a stressful time during my
career my mom proceeds to pull out these
two antenna-like rods shaped like the
letter l while holding the short end of
the rod she proceeds to walk up to meet
and go
to meet in the rods m-e-e-t
and the rods move closer together in her
hands
she says i am surrounded by negative
activity wait a minute what kind of
which craft will we talk while holding
the short end of the rod she proceeds to
walk up
to meet me i think is what you meant to
say and the rods move closer together in
hands i'm going to just guess that she
says i'm surrounded by negative activity
she then proceeds to make me think of
the most positive thoughts i can
envision
such as the births
what the f dude you've got to finish
your sentences birth of your son i guess
is what that means she then steps back
and then while i love how you use the
word whom correctly i'm assuming and
then you can't get this other [ __ ] right
she then steps back and then while i'm
supposedly thinking positive thoughts
she walks backwards to more of me and
the rods slowly separate apart she
comments that the spirits are now in my
favor
like an [ __ ] i thought of the most
depressing thoughts i could just to
prove that she was moving the damn rods
herself after pointing it out my mom
freaks out and breaks out crying and
yelling saying how much of a jerk i am
that i will that i should respect her
abilities
and they aren't to be toyed with
jesus christ she sounds like she's going
to stab you with a butter knife
you know what i just thought of i just
thought of misery like you're going to
wake up tied to the bed and she's going
to be standing there
with [ __ ] lightning going off in the
background
what a [ __ ] your mom's a jerk dude
you busted her for lying and then she
uses the age-old [ __ ] woman
um manipulating technique of crying
right
he should have held her to it
it's like you're yelling at me because
you're lying
you lied to me mom
how could you do that
put the [ __ ] tv antenna down
all right
sit down have a [ __ ] sandwich what's
wrong with you
he says i love my mom bill and i just
want her to come to her senses obviously
jokes don't help to persuade her
that she isn't nostradamus any advice
you or nia might have would be
appreciated maybe it's just me but this
whole spiritualism [ __ ] feels like a fad
just like the show long island medium i
don't know that show um
yeah i don't know what to i don't know
does she have a job
is she sick of her career and she's
trying to go the tarot card reading
thing
i have no i don't know what to say to
you there i bet i mean i would give her
[ __ ] like mom you you lied to me
all right
you're sitting there saying that uh
you're like you're healing me
and you're not
i i don't know when somebody goes crazy
dude i don't know i don't know what to
tell you
you either gotta roll with it or you
gotta
i wouldn't want to bring it to a doctor
because god knows they're gonna put her
all on the latest drugs
and use her as a [ __ ] guinea pig so
i might try to avoid that um
i don't know dude i feel like i'm
letting you down here but
i'd rather not give you any advice
because i don't have any rather than
give you some bad
advice i'm freaks out i love my mom any
advice she might
how to make her come to her senses
um
i don't know why don't you go buy a
magic kit and get better at it than she
is
and then somehow try to turn her into
your student
and just one day just say that she
failed
you know that she needs to go back to
being a mom
just grow out a long beard and start
wearing all white and sick [ __ ]
indian style the lotus position i
believe it's called
and uh
you know like candles and stuff that'll
give you credibility with her and just
tell her that she's uh
you know she's not good at it
now that's to make her cry again
i don't know
no disrespect to meryl streep but they
can all do it on command you know i'm
not saying she's not a good actress and
doesn't deserve those [ __ ] shiny
trophies but
i i don't know what to tell you they
just can do it the drop of a [ __ ] hat
she's sitting there with two tv antennas
and the guy her own son busts her for
lying and immediately she can start
crying
there's not a guy in the world that
could [ __ ] pull that emotion
out of their ass like that
or are there menopause [ __ ]
i'm sorry and i just talked bad about
your mom
her uh post menopause vagina
okay let's let's do you know what i
think that's a nice segue into this next
uh advertisement
trying to beat two strokes people
stamps.com
with the holiday almost here you don't
have time to go to the post office
traffic parking it will be packed with
everybody mailing their holiday gifts
and packages so do what i do
use stamps.com instead with stamps.com
you can avoid all the hassle man or go
to the post office during the busy
holiday season everything you would do
at the post office you can do right at
your desk buy and print official u.s
postage using your own computer and
printer
print postage for any letter or package
the ins the instant you need it
then the mailman picks it up so easy and
convenient i use stamps.com to send out
all my dvds all of my posters my
t-shirts whatever i'm selling that week
i'm a [ __ ] if i can figure out how to
do it so can you right now get this
special offer when you use my last name
bur b-u-r-r for a no-risk trial plus 110
dollar bonus offer includes a digital
scale and up to 55 dollars free postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else click on the microphone
at the top of the home page and type in
bur that's stop calm enter burr b-u-r-r
was that one under
what was it two was there a hiccup in
there i don't think so
um e-voice
the holidays are coming and as a
business owner you know what that means
crickets
i don't get that
face it the next couple of months are
the combo oh i get it now
let me read this again evoice the
holidays are coming and the uh jesus
christ take three take three let me get
some water here
oh god that's good e-voice the holidays
are coming and as a business owner you
know what that means crickets face it
the next couple of months of the calm
before the storm now is the time to do
something that will dramatically help
your 2014. e-voice e-voice is the simple
technology that helps you to make more
money
uh with e-voice toll-free or local
numbers call routing tools and a
professional dial by name directory your
business will look like a million bucks
and with e-voice
if you can if you can't take a call they
will transcribe the voicemail and email
it to you you'll never be caught off
guard again evoy says saving has been
saving companies thousands of dollars
every month making them more efficient
and more productive there's no quicker
or easy way to transfer your business
transform your business for 2014. and
with e-voice you can
i'm just going to throw my bag of clubs
right in the water and with e-voice you
can try it before you buy it right now
you can get a 30-day trial to e-voice
when you go to e-voice dot com slash bar
or go to billboard.com and click on the
e-voice banner that's evoice.com
billboard billboard or billboard.com and
click on the e-voice banner now's the
time to check take charge of your
business and prepare for a productive
2014. go to evoice.com billboard or go
to billboard.com and click on the
e-voice banner for your free 30-day
trial
that's evoice dot com slash billboard
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner
jesus [ __ ] christ how many times i
got to try to say my name
um
concerned brother
hey bill
love the show well thank you he says i
got a situation i could use some advice
my sister is 16 years old and dating a
22 year old what the [ __ ] yeah i got
advice go out to the goddamn garage and
get a [ __ ] shovel
dig the hole first
uh don't do that i'm not advocating
murder
just bury him alive for a few minutes
um
they met at a church function oh for
[ __ ] sakes
dude this is making me upset
my sister is 16 year old 16 years old
and she's dating a 22 year old they met
at a church function over a year ago and
even though he lives two states away
they've been keeping in contact what the
[ __ ] dude how many more sexual predator
red flags do you need
he goes i just found out my parents have
invited him to thanksgiving this year
do you live in like the middle east or
something is this some sort of custom
that is
widely accepted in some far away land
my initial reaction is to beat the [ __ ]
out of this [ __ ] creep
oh beat the [ __ ] out of this [ __ ]
creep sorry i don't think that that will
solve anything in the long run so i'm
trying to keep a level head and be
mature about this but to be honest with
you i haven't got a [ __ ] clue as to
what to do my parents are obviously
mentally unstable and i'm not equipped
to talk sense into a 16 year old girl so
if you could tell me what to say to this
guy to make him understand in a
non-violent way that this is wrong it
needs to stop i'd appreciate it see dude
you're going on the same journey i i
started
you found out immediately i'm thinking
i'm getting a shovel and i'm burying
this [ __ ] guy in the ground but you
know as i know violence is not the way
he goes the scariest thing about this
is that in this weird ass church my
family belongs to
several of my sister's friends have
gotten married at 17 and 18
and that just can't happen here i know
this is a [ __ ] up situation but i'd be
grateful for any help you
you have to offer thank you and go [ __ ]
yourself yeah i would look up uh some
stuff about cults
i would get some professional help on
this one dude you know people ask me
advice on this you know it's usually
much lighter than this
but dude you're talking about
god forbid if this guy's hooking up with
you you literally have a sex offender
on your hands here can you get the local
authorities involved can you call the
cops
i mean i i don't know i have no idea
what to do i'm afraid if you do
something like that it's gonna make her
run into his arms
even further
what the [ __ ]
yeah i don't know what to do because you
can't get violent with the guy
i don't know
i i have no idea and i don't know if
you're making a joke about your parents
being mentally unstable dude this is
like some dr drew [ __ ] calling dr drew
if you're going to go the show business
route all right because he's actually a
professional i'm a [ __ ] idiot so
don't listen to me but i would try to
get some professional help
and with every fiber in my being i hope
that you [ __ ] solve this problem
because that guy
that guy should be living in a [ __ ]
dumpster
the [ __ ] kind of a what the f you're 22.
you know that's one of those guys when
he's [ __ ] 32 he's still to be going
after 16 year olds i [ __ ] guarantee
it
that's just [ __ ] that is [ __ ] creepy
the difference in age
between 16 and 22 is a [ __ ] lifetime
that's disgusting
uh i don't know sir i would get
professional health i'm sorry there's
nothing [ __ ] funny about that at all
um
all right from a young lady oh this is
great
a woman writing it i've been trying to
get women to write in
but you know
they probably shut off my podcast
because they're decent human beings from
a young lady uh dear bill i'm a 16 year
old [ __ ] we're back to 16 year old women
and the only guess you're dating this 22
year old guy and your [ __ ]
your older brother is getting in the way
of the relationship
all right i'm six i'm a 16 year old lady
who loves stand-up comedy and it's my
dream to do headlining stand up when i
grow up currently i'm taking stand-up
classes with blah blah blah not going to
say who at the at the place in this city
and this other city
someday i want to open for you but i
want some advice and a favor a favor oh
geez
um i know that it will take a while for
me to be amazing at stand up so what
should i do when i bomb on stage do i
just keep bombing i've only done one
stand-up show but i surprisingly did
well oh good for you you did better than
i did
i only did okay um
what should i do after high school i
want to move to la and just to open mic
and take classes it will be hard though
since i'm not 21 i have to wait outside
the clubs which is so annoying
but if you have a better idea please
tell me
uh because you know what you're talking
about lastly the favor it would be
amazing if you did an all-ages show in
los angeles to san diego thank you for
your time
uh just so you know you're the reason i
want to do stand-up because you're
freaking hilarious that's great
all right well first of all you're way
ahead of the game you're only 16 years
old i didn't start until i was almost
24.
um
as far as moving to la i would not do
that
i would not do that i would move to a
town i would probably more if i was you
i would move to maybe san francisco
uh
i would move to a city that has a good
comedy scene where you can develop and
learn how to be a comedian and get some
momentum going before you try and start
in la la is the hardest place
as far as i can tell in america to start
doing stand-up comedy because you have
all these professional comics who now
feel they're ready to take a shot
moving to la and they're all getting on
stage and that they're having problems
trying to get on stage at least i did
back in the day and um
so i would
give yourself time to
develop and um
all right what else did you ask
uh
what did you say you said how do what
are you doing you're bombing um
bombing is just
that's just a part of it
um
so what'd you say
what should you do if you start bombing
on stage i don't know make fun of the
joke that you just told it didn't work
make fun of yourself
you just gotta stand there and take it
and you'll figure out your own way how
to get through it but when you're bombed
don't get down on yourself because it
happens to everybody i've been working
on a bit this whole weekend it's been
i've been eating my balls on it every
[ __ ] night
and it's pissing me off because i know
it's funny i just don't know how to make
it funny yet so that part of it never
ends
uh what else did you say
what should i do after high school don't
move to la i wouldn't i wouldn't advise
that
i would not advise that
i would advise i already said what to do
um
is that it other than that just [ __ ]
right [ __ ] that you think's funny
don't hang out with negative people that
bring you down don't hang out with other
comics who are weirdly competing with
you
and happy slash resenting your success
you know get rid of those [ __ ] people
cuz hang around positive motivated
people
and then you guys you create your own
[ __ ] start filming it and then you come
here and you storm the castle you'll be
the new wave
and i'll be wanting to get into your
movie so be on your tv show all right so
good luck to you i think that's awesome
that you're doing it at 16. you got more
courage than i ever had
all right here we go
trying to stop masturbating
well you're talking to the wrong person
[Laughter]
uh talking to you about stop
masturbating you might as well talk to
colonel sanders about stop frying
chicken
taking the edge off bill buford hoping
you get the drummer reference of course
i do um or is it beaufort i was never
like into was did he play for a yes he
played for one of those prog bands of
the 70s
didn't he
i have no idea a big fan of your work
and i thought
bill buford right
i used to get him and alan white
confused i don't know why big fan of
your work and i thought i'd get your
input on this i'm trying to stop jerking
off i'm not afraid of going blind or
getting hairy palms or any of that [ __ ]
i've even read that there are health
benefits to masturbating my my my
primary concern is that i'm beginning to
develop premature ejaculation
i've never heard of that
i'm not premature exaggeration but by
jerking off that you're
well maybe you know yourself too well
right there boom right there boom you're
just [ __ ] all it's over
um i also can't help but feel disgusted
whenever i bust one off call it catholic
guilt yeah it is catholic guilt um i
don't masturbate
on an insane basis only once every two
or three days
jesus christ dude
you know you're like a [ __ ] dh in my
world
[Laughter]
um
[ __ ] relief pitcher uh but it's the
only sexual activity i'm getting at the
moment and i can't go more than around
nine days without an intense urge to do
it dude this is really getting too
personal for me i have a small dick and
i'm fine with that learning to accept
that my dick has below is below average
in length has freed me from my
penis envy and it was a
disproportionately large weight off my
chest
it's the sexual equivalent to the last
rap battle in eight mile you can't tell
me [ __ ] i don't already know but having
a small dick and being a minute man is
more than i can take yeah you don't want
the combo platter there uh i know that
you've advised people to rub one off
rub one out on a different occasion and
i respect that because things definitely
come into perspective after you finish
masturbating but can you suggest any
method for people who are trying to hold
back
on choking the chicken thanks in advance
and go [ __ ] yourself no i can't
i can't i don't think there's anything
wrong with it
you know
i think if most the dictators in the
world would [ __ ] rub one out or get a
goddamn handy from some [ __ ] chick
dressed like a nurse
i don't think that'd be any war until
like two in the afternoon
uh
i don't know
you definitely don't want to just be
doing that to yourself you want to be in
some sort of a [ __ ] relationship uh
you're fine with having a small dick as
far as that goes yeah
i would definitely go downtown first
make sure you know she's one up on you
and then [ __ ] have at it but you
didn't ask me about that so i i don't
know i don't know i'm throwing this one
to dr drew again
trying to hold back joking i i don't
think there's anything wrong with it
that's the premature ejaculation thing i
think might be a problem
yeah it is a problem you said you don't
want that so i i would consult a uh you
guys you guys are really hit me with
some heavy ones this week
you know
i don't know what to tell you do i would
contact a uh
therapist a sex therapist or some [ __ ]
um
let's see what the [ __ ] would i do
if i was premature ejaculating
uh
[Music]
i would rub two out
and then i'd take my exhausted dick out
and then i would see i'd have a go then
see how that happens
that's all i got
right that's what you get when you
listen to a free podcast that's the kind
of advice you get
um
yeah i would go to a professional
all right there we go
wow those last two were brutal
oh the last two out of three
except for the uh the standard committee
one was awesome that was a nice reprieve
um anyway so that's the podcast for this
week i will be tweeting and facebooking
uh all the final details about the
garage
uh sale the all things comedy garage
sale and um
you can call us up bid on some stuff it
helps the wounded warriors project i'm
also doing a quick spot at the lap
factory
um for rob schneider's show uh all the
proceeds will be benefiting um all the
victims
and the survivors
i guess i should say of uh
that typhoon out there in the
philippines um
and that's it that's my week i gotta i
think i got a gig in new haven this
weekend and i'm going to the harvard
yale game
how [ __ ] awesome is that
i will be probably sitting amongst at
least the next three presidents when i
go to that game i'm really looking
forward to it stuff one of the first
bowls i think it is the first bowl that
was built in this country as far as
stadiums uh
so i'm really excited to see a game
there i'll be there with dude i called
it paul verzi and i'm actually going to
bet the cowboys with them next week just
to make this fun this whole bet um
him calling it all right that's the
podcast for this week go [ __ ] yourselves
i'll talk to you next week
[Applause]
[Music]
if see you again
so
[Music]
all night
the vacant notion of the city lights
the vacuum faces
it wasn't that long ago
[Music]
is
so
[Music]
you